Russian forces appear to be regrouping
for a possible assault on Kiev new
satellite images from U.S company maxar
technology show military units deploying
closer to the capital according to the
company's analysis the images show
artillery firing towards residential
areas as well as burning homes and other
buildings widespread damage and impact
craters can also be seen in a town
Northwest of Kiev
and concern is also growing over the
besieged southern Port of mariupole
Ukrainian officials say more than 1 500
people have been killed by writers into
the city have thwarted repeated attempts
to bring in food and water and evacuate
trapped civilians
and authorities in Ukraine have released
CCTV footage they say shows Russian
forces apprehending the mayor of
multiple Ivan federov Ukraine says
Russian forces kidnapped him after
falsely accusing him of terrorism
and meanwhile Russia is expanding its
military campaign across other parts of
Ukraine intensifying attacks on cities
and hitting new targets with bombs and
missile strikes
the city of danipro in eastern Ukraine a
new front in Russia's War
Emergency Services said at least three
missiles hit civilian targets here
including this shoe factory for Ukraine
another sign that Russia is deliberately
targeting civilians
we see more destruction of Civilian
infrastructure murder of ukrainians by a
terrorist State the Russian Federation
Russia also launched attacks on lutzka
nivano francovsk two cities in western
Ukraine far from the main battle zones
the Kremlin unilaterally announced
humanitarian corridors in places
including mariupole harghief Genevieve
and Sumi
the first residents of Sumi who managed
to flee via one of the corridors arrived
in the western city of leviv
or
trains fly over us and bomb our street
several times it was horrible I took the
kids and hid
they bombed our streets our buildings
our homes
one of the bombs killed 22 people
three of them children the whole family
died
outside the capitol Kiev Ukrainian
forces continued to battle Russian
troops
Ukraine says military victories here
have stalled the Russian offensive on
the city President Vladimir silenski
sounded a defiant tone
it's impossible to say how many days we
still have to free Ukrainian land but we
can't say we will do it because we want
it we have already reached a strategic
turning point we are moving towards our
goal towards our victory
in central Kiev Airaid Sirens rang out
again Russian forces are within Striking
Distance the battle for Kiev will be
decisive in the outcome of this war
and for more let's bring in DW's
correspondent Nick Connelly who's in
cave Nick Air Raid Sirens were heard
again in the morning how was the night
there
well I think aeroid Sirens just are part
of daily life not only in Kiev but in
most big cities or in Ukraine now we're
in the third week of war and to be
honest lots of people have given up
going down to their sellers finding a
metro station every time they hear it
because basically you couldn't get a
look get through your day without
spending most of your time hiding there
are so many of these because some lots
of these Rockets are coming from Belarus
was very close so the system is not able
to identify immediately which city which
direction those missiles are going so
basically all cities in the kind of
broader area that could be hit have
those Sirens so basically it's pretty
unspecific and uh yeah obviously
terrifying when you hear that when you
hear it on the ground when you hear it
on the radio when you're driving around
the town but I think it's something that
lots of ukrainians got used to we have
been hearing some big bangs it's
difficult to tell what they are
sometimes those are anti-aircraft
systems working knocking out rockets
that are being heading heading this way
obviously here it's one of the main
targets but also has some of the best
anti-aircraft facilities that Ukraine
has there also been reports of Ukrainian
troops blowing up Bridges to the West in
the direction of European that town that
we've seen thousands of people trying to
get out of in recent days trying to make
it difficult for Russia to come in
closer from that direction so it is it
is it is difficult it is scary because
you can't identify even people with
military experience can't necessarily
identify where those Banks coming from
what they are but people are getting
used to it because that is just their
daily reality and for the people that
you meet here in key of most of the kind
of two million people estimated still to
be here in Kiev they have made their
choice that they're staying
Nick with that said does it seem or is
it apparent that the Russians have
rethought their strategy in the last 48
hours
well obviously there's a little
conjecture based on those satellite
images that for instance the Russians
here closer to Kiev r on the one hand
spreading their the hardware more thinly
because there have been lots of attacks
by Ukrainian drones Ukrainian Aviation
on areas on places where the Russians
had concentrated their forces are busy
made it easier for the ukrainians to hit
them from the air then there's other uh
conjunctional analysis that the Russians
are now using more missile strikes
missile strikes coming from Belarus or
from further field from Russia proper
um because the ukrainians are proving to
be quite successful on the ground when
it comes to kind of direct Combat on the
roads in The Villages of Ukraine those
Western weapons that Ukraine has been
receiving in recent months those
anti-tank missiles those Stinger
anti-aircraft missiles are proving quite
effective so the Russians trying to Ram
home their advantage in those parts of
kind of military hardware that Ukraine
can't match Russia on
um but I think for now it's it's too
early to tell yesterday evening people
were very worried here that the Russians
were going to bring Belarus into this so
for now Russian forces have been using
Belushi airfields have come in from
Belarus but they haven't used the
Belarusian Army yet and there was worry
yesterday here in Ukraine that the
Russians would organize some kind of
false flag operation that would seem to
be Ukraine attacking Belarus as a
pretext for Belarus to come into this
war on Russia's side that doesn't seem
to have happened overnight but it's very
difficult to tell what exactly is
happening there are very few independent
journalists on the ground exactly where
the fighting is their censorship
military censorship on both sides but uh
yeah for now there is a worry the
Russians are now regrouping and trying
to prepare some kind of assault on Kiev
given that it's proven so difficult for
them to capture Ukraine's capital in the
recent days
just briefly do we know anything about
the fate or the well-being of melatopo's
Mayor Ivan federov
well these have been extraordinary
pictures from cities in southern Ukraine
that are now under Russian control of
civil resistance unarmed resistance
people going out and protesting getting
on Russian tanks with the Ukrainian
flags and basically just saying we don't
want you here and the same goes for the
mayor of that City who has refused to go
along with what the Russian forces want
him to do we've seen images yesterday
that seem to show him being kidnapped
and there is a demonstration plan in
that city today this morning by locals
to demand his release it's very
difficult to get in contact with people
there because mobile phone networks are
down and there are issues with
connectivity but it does seem that he is
in Russian custody and the locals at
least lots of them are willing to take
the risk of standing up to those Russian
forces in their City to demand that
their Ukrainian democratically elected
mayor be released and be allowed to do
his job
the W correspondent Nick Connelly in
Kiev thank you
we're joined Now by class vitna he's a
retired Brigadier General of the German
Armed Forces welcome to you sir the I
want to begin by asking if you expect
this increasingly heavy bombardment of
Kiev and other Ukrainian cities to
continue if not escalate in coming days
and weeks
absolutely as we see that is the change
of strategy across the board the land
campaign has been slowed down to an
unexpected extent and uh so they will
increase the bombardment of the cities
and particularly
Kiev as we see
the Russian military is still trying to
encircle the city uh the capital but
with limited success as your
correspondent has described the troops
are regrouping artillery is in position
but I think entering the city in
strength is still far off also because
the defense preparations by the
ukrainians are very strong in Personnel
in uh block uh barricades in traps in
anti-tank arms and anti-air systems and
all this led by the charismatic uh
president who uh motive and the
Klitschko brothers who motivate the
whole nation right The Limited success
you speak of Russia is one of the
biggest military powers in the world but
has been tested here before the eyes of
the world has it passed that test for
you
can you repeat the question I'm just
saying that Russia is one of the biggest
armies in the world they've been tested
here have they passed that test
have they have they misjudged you mean
have they is their army performing well
well I think apart from the misjudgment
regarding Western Unity uh International
shaming and isolation and sanctions uh
of course uh protein has miscalculated
in military terms and totally
underestimated the Ukrainian resolve and
resistance the Kremlin thought of a
subjugation Blitzkrieg as it were but
now we are on day 17 of the war with the
limited advance and for that logistical
preparations over long distances were
totally insufficient food fools spare
parts Etc and there was also a
misjudgment about the losses among the
deplorable young Russian soldiers who
have a very poor fighting morale and
motivation because they were not
prepared for fighting a war in a brother
country
no flight zones over Ukraine have been
discussed and and seems to be set aside
for Fears of what Russia will do in
response where do you think Russia's red
line is for considering NATO support for
Ukraine an act of aggression against
Russia
let me start by uh saying that yesterday
in um in a webinar a former security and
or a Breedlove uh criticized how we are
totally deterred by proteins tempers
indeed for this criminal aggression
he constructed the pretext all by
himself
and does not need our provocations
on the one hand of course a no-fly zone
would mean that NATO planes shoot down
Russian planes over Ukraine territory
that would indeed lead to a war between
Russia and the United States that must
be avoided on the other hand Mick 29
from Poland for Ukraine I found totally
acceptable but the operation was sadly
spoiled by a harmful public debate one
should have not everyone should not have
talked about it in the public by night
one should have changed the national
emblems
Ukraine Ukrainian Pilots would have come
to the Polish Airfield to enter the
planes and flown them to Ukraine and
with much without much do through the
public discussion this option was about
it so to
Speakman retired Brigadier General thank
you so much for your thoughts
thank you have a good day
well in the 16 days since the war
started the UN says more than 2.5
million people have fled Ukraine nearly
half of them to Poland DW's baguetta
shulker traveled to the city of
fisherman near the border with Ukraine
and filed this report
Escaping The War Zone they're trained
finally arrives in Poland hundreds of
women and children is a bug to safety at
platform number five in chemical station
Olga and her two children have been
traveling for three days and freezing
nights they are exhausted but relieved
to be getting help the house in khakif
was destroyed in a Russian air raid
they kept bombing us it didn't stop we
had to take shelter in the bunker and we
were trapped there for days that's when
we decided
it was horrific the children didn't stop
crying we tried to comfort them and try
to stay calm but inside we were also
shaken
they show us blurry photos of hakif the
city in Ruins their husbands are still
there because they are not allowed to
leave the country
four-year-old Vanya doesn't understand
why
I miss my daddy
we went on the train and we were going
and going and going
in the entrance hall hundreds of
volunteers provide the new arrivals with
food water clothes free SIM cards and
advice
like Olga many don't know where to go
from here know what to do next
every day 5 to 10 trains from Ukraine
arrive here at the station and the
number continues to grow to help all the
arriving refugees has become a major
challenge for the small city of
tremechel which itself has only 60 000
citizens
the city's mayor will check bakun is
coordinating the humanitarian relief
effort since the war in Ukraine began he
says he hasn't had more than four hours
sleep a day he's proud that his city has
managed to provide help but is worried
he doesn't know how long they can keep
it up we are we are the city hall not
you know Humanity organization so we
will not do this for for a long time or
for forever you know just we try talk
with some organization to help us for a
long long period of time
key he tells us is to quickly relocate
the refugees to other cities
Olga has finally decided to continue her
journey to Warsaw before a train leaves
she addresses all NATO States
I want to tell them to impose a no-fly
zone because our families are still
there my parents my brother our husbands
are there I want my family to survive I
want the bombing to stop
Olga plans to call her husband and her
parents she doesn't have the strength
yet because she's afraid they might not
answer
for more let's bring in Matthew's salt
marsh currently in the southeast of
Poland close to the Ukrainian border
he's the spokesman of the unhcr the U.N
Refugee agency welcome to you Matthew
just wondering first up whether you
expect the flow of people out of Ukraine
2.5 million of them so far do you expect
this enormous flow of people will
continue
well as you said that number has now
passed the two and a half million
barrier it went through yesterday
Poland here is taking the Lion's Share
one and a half million with also
significant numbers around the
neighboring countries but also moving
Westward
as to whether it will continue yes there
will be more people coming the scale of
that and the speed of that obviously
depends very much on what happens on the
ground in Ukraine uh intensification of
conflict or not
um safe passages out of cities and
whether people decide that it's not safe
enough to move from the western part of
the country
um and then and then cross the border so
so those are there's a number of factors
but of course the numbers will keep
rising in the last couple of days
the border that I've been at near here
in medika has been a little bit quieter
than it had been in previous days pretty
clearly Matthew these millions of people
need a lot but what is needed most
urgently right now
well I think up on the border the
immediate needs are obviously uh lawn
clothing blankets hot foods that's being
provided for uh by ngos by the Polish
authorities so again we really have to
have to thank them I think as more
people come in and they are triaged out
and away from the border the question
then becomes more of reception and
accommodation and secondary services
around things like health and trauma
support and child support and so on so
initially the polls have done a
fantastic job and those spaces that
accommodation is there as things move on
the questions arise as to what will be
the next steps
you allude to it so far the refugees are
mainly in the neighboring countries to
Ukraine are they already thoughts or or
plans coming together about how they
could be distributed throughout Europe
well obviously that's a question for the
European Union
um relocation has been attempted before
by the EU in the serious situation uh
there weren't huge numbers successfully
uh transferred into different states
um so we'll have to see I think what
happens with the numbers that arrive in
different states whether those states
have the capacity to absorb them whether
they feel that other neighbors need to
step in and take take some numbers I
think it's a little bit early to be
speculating about that but it's
definitely something that that
policymakers in the EU will be thinking
about at the moment
at the salt marsh from the unhcr thanks
so much
thank you
okay here's a look now at some of the
other developments in the conflict and
the international atomic energy agency
says power has been partially restored
to Chernobyl nuclear power station the
site of the 1986 nuclear disaster
Ukrainian technicians say they are
repairing the plant which was seized by
Russian forces early in the war the
power supply is critical to keep
reactive rods there cooled
U.S troops continue to be deployed to
Europe adding to thousands who have
already been sent to support NATO allies
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
about 130 soldiers left the U.S state of
Georgia the Pentagon has ordered roughly
12 000 service members from the U.S
bases to Europe
Spain's energy and food prices have
surged with electricity more than
doubling since before the Russian war on
Ukraine it has affected Spain's grain
Imports and driven up oil and gas prices
the Spanish prime minister has pledged
subsidies to support those most
seriously hit
or the EU Summit in Versailles has been
dominated by the conflict in Ukraine and
the beleaguered nation's request for
Fast Track entry into the EU the 27
leaders declined to alter the conditions
for Ukraine to join the group saying it
we'll have to follow the procedure for
entry but they left the door to
membership slightly open calls from some
EU members to immediately stop Russian
oil and gas were also unsuccessful
although there was agreement to move
away from fuel dependence on Russia by
2027.
well for more on that I'm joined by DW
correspondent Barbara basil in
Versailles where that informal EU Summit
took place Barbara the EU leaders
decided on a big policy change on energy
and defense here where's the biggest
shift
Union because they had to acknowledge
all their
patrons their ideologies and their
beliefs throughout the last 10 maybe
even 20 years were simply wrong they
thought that the world was a reliable
place with their neighbors like Russia
being closely tied to Europe by trade
and by Financial ties and this has
proven to be horribly untrue so their
security is seriously threatened so they
have to sort of reformulate everything
energy policy it means that they will
try to get off Russian oil and gas they
want to diminish it by two-thirds till
the end of the year defense they have
found out and and sort of really noticed
that they are totally defenseless
without American troops that Russia
could aggress have in a war and start a
war of regression against them as well
theoretically so they will now have a
common defense projects they know they
will have to spend much more money with
talking about billions for defense of
the member states and for common
projects so this is just complete change
in everything and it is a hard thing to
do there were bitter and long
discussions there are many things you're
talking about will take a long time but
what was decided concerning further
sanctions and a possible oil and gas
boycott of Russia
of course is the elephant and was the
elephant in the room here in the Chateau
of Versailles behind me because this was
talked about when the Finnish prime
minister arrived here as she said we are
financing Putin's War by buying oil and
gas from Russia and she was totally
right and everybody in those luxurious
rooms there knows it but they said we
can't do it yet we somehow don't know
how to tell our citizens that prices for
energy will go through the roof now
they're trying to sort of find
intermediate measures but we don't know
yet they might yet come to the point of
things in UK Ukraine get worse and worse
and if Putin sort of piles up atrocities
against the Ukrainian people they might
find themselves before us politically to
cut off those oil and gas deliveries
before we go Barbara Ukraine's hope of
fast-tracked EU membership is that hope
all but done for
that was a bit weak it was a diplomatic
formula of course yes you're part of our
family and we want you and eventually
you can come but it didn't give them any
immediate hope and it didn't really put
them on a fast track as a candidate
which was it would have been the first
formal step it was to to tell them that
yes you can start to sort of go towards
becoming a member of the European Union
and so this sort of like Little Ray of
Hope that Vladimir zielinski had tried
to give his people the west where and
Europe they want to they accept you they
will take you in that wasn't really
given to them and so that was much less
than could have happened many Eastern
European countries left here and said
we're disappointed this could have been
better Barbara Fazil in Versailles thank
you